welcome back to 8701
so this is our last video in the chapter
on adrenal physics
and we'll talk about mass scales and the
nature of the neutrino particle
very briefly when we think about how we
can measure the neutrino
masses there's a number of methods which
come to mind
the first one is to you know just look
out
into the universe and try to understand
how much matter
in total could come from
as a source from neutrinos and
one has to make assumptions about the
model the cosmological models
at hand but if one accepts us those
potential biases or model dependencies
one finds that there's a reach potential
rate of this kind of mass measurements
of
20 to 50 meb milli electron volts
and the current best limits are in the
order of 0.1 to
1 electron volt a second source and i'll
talk more about this later
is the study of neutrino less better
decay double beta decays
here the current best limits are in the
order of 0.2 to 0.4 electron volts and
there's a
chance to reach 20 to 50 million
electron voice
this kind of measurement will also
answer the question whether or not the
neutrino
is a direct particle or marijuana
particle as we discussed in earlier
lectures
and then there is the more classical
approach of measuring the mass of
a neutrino from the endpoint spectrum
of beta decays and so here the current
best limit
is from the catrin experiment and i'll
talk about this on the next slide
and it's in the order of one electron
volt and there's a potential reach to go
down to 40
million electrons so currently so the
range
is in the order of the the range of
of limits is in the order of one
electron volts or a bit better
and one will be able to go down to
limits in the order of 20 to 50
milli electrons so here is
in a cartoon of how those measurements
are being conducted
one starts with trithium
and uses better decay
and this lecture overall is a good kind
of
first entry into the nuclear physics
program where we discuss better decays
and other nuclear decays in more detail
what we find here is that you find an
electron and then
neutrino anti-neutrino in this case
being emitted
and so the the name of the game is now
to measure the electron energy
as precisely as possible and then
find a sensitivity of the neutrino mass
in the endpoint spectrum
and those small differences here in the
endpoint spectrum
there then leads to understanding of the
mass of the nurturing
neutrino because
the total energy in the collision needs
to be preserved and so
the entire story here is about how
precisely can we measure
the energy of the electron in order to
infer the neutrino mass
in there and so the latest result came
out last year
from the cartoon experiment um and shows
that we can set an upper limb the result
is consistent with a neutrino mass of
zero
and that we can set an upper limit at
ninety percent confidence level
that's a neutrino electron neutrino
is of mass of 1.1
electron volt
just as a reminder we measure the mass
of the electron neutrino in this decay
which is the sum
of the individual components um
mass eigenstate which make up the
electromagnet
um to set the historical context in this
discussion here
we find you know that this latest result
is an improvement of the order a factor
of two compared to previous result
um by by other experiments which has a
very
very similar very similar job to measure
the electron
energy in better decays in the endpoint
the endpoint spectrum of better decays
there's a new new approach which has
been proposed by
geofomacio here from mit
um which changes the way the electron
energy is being measured
so the idea is to have the decay happen
in
in magnetic fields and use um the
klystron
cytosol cyclotron radiation of single
electrons
so the the the advantage here is that
one doesn't have to move the electron
somehow
into a spectrometer but can immediately
measure
um the energy of the electron
and the measurement of the energy then
turns into a measurement of the
frequency
and basically measures the cycle turn
frequency
of the electron circling around in a
magnetic field
and so it turns out that one one moves
the measurement of the energy of the
electron into a measurement
of of a frequency and those frequency
can be measured with very very high
precision
so there's some
some hope that this kind of measurement
lead to
very very precise results of the
energy of the electron and reset the
mass of the nutrient
so the last slide here is now how can we
figure out whether or not the neutrino
has
the rock or majorana nature and this can
be done
or the highest sensitivity comes from
so-called neutrinoless double beta
decays so one starts with nuclear decays
where two electrons are emitted
no neutrino and so this requires that in
this process
there's a transition which includes
neutrino where the neutrino has to be
its own anti-particle
and that just means that the neutrino is
of marijuana nature
this is being done by measuring again
the energy spectrum
you typically have background all kinds
of background contributions but also
backgrounds
from double beta decays with two
neutrinos
so you see the spectrum here and then
you look at the endpoint of this part
here and
find that there's this peak a very
precise
sharp peak of energies of the energies
of the two electrons
the issue is that forecasting where this
peak is
requires a proper knowledge of this of
the dynamics
inside the nuclei here
and you know those measurements are
being conducted
there's many of them conducted in
various nuclear transitions or decays
and they haven't yielded a positive
result yet
research is still going on in this